i do believe this is the first time he's
ever been on the show we've been on the
air for seven years i can't believe it
um you know he broadcasts games with one
of my favorite people on the planet
uh in chris fowler he is emmy nominated
for his great work in calling these
games you see him on nfl on
college game day and he's also an author
of a new book
called out of the pocket football
fatherhood and college game day
saturdays he will be part
of the espn abc disney family of
networks coverage
of the nfl draft he is kirk herb street
how are you kirk
i'm great bud how are you i'm better for
talking to you happy draft week
happy drafting yeah same to you it's
fine it's finally here i know
my gosh and it just seems the talent
evaluation portion of the of the nfl
calendar gets longer and longer each
year
and i would have to say that justin
fields probably has had about enough of
it
right about now yeah i think i think a
lot of these guys i mean it happens
every year
you know especially at that position and
the fact that we have so many of them
you know
it just leads to uh you know nitpicking
and
everybody's going to have an opinion the
only people that matter obviously are
going to be on thursday and friday
on saturday when they when they make
these decisions but yeah i think these
players
you know they all say the right things
oh you know it's part of it but
uh you know we're all human and when
anytime you're going to get criticized
it's it's not fun so yeah i think
they're
they're ready to be done with it and
hear their names selected well justin
fields in particular kirk
i mean yeah you know uh because the the
night that the ohio state and i think i
am saying it properly
uh i didn't say ohio state i don't
really get that i never really have
well you know just so so then we'll
we'll just go ohio state and i'll take
all the tweets
um but the night ohio state just
absolutely took care of business to say
the least against clemson
fields was electric i mean he made every
possible throw
to me that was like an actual real live
pro day where he was
making all the throws on a route tree
and ever since then
all we're hearing is he's not trevor
lawrence he's not zach wilson that it
was mack jones who was traded up for
now maybe it's trey lance and the last
thing i'm hearing now
is you know mac jones has shown how
smart he is in the room and trey lance
is as well and now the
the the i guess um the whole concept
you're hearing
we're not saying justin's not smart but
it just makes no it's it's nuts so i
just want your
full evaluation of justin fields of all
the games of his that you've called
about what what he's bringing to the
table here and i just did this qb 21
with
with all these guys and and kind of went
over an
hour with with each each of them and got
to know him
on a whole different level even though
i'm you know when you do these
production meetings you get around these
programs
you get to know them on a pretty good
level but
um i'm it's not that you have to
put one up and knock another one down i
i'm very impressed with
with all these guys but i don't
understand if you just asked me from
covering football as closely as i do the
college game
and you said tell me about these college
quarterbacks i would have said going
into the season it was
trevor lawrence 1a justin fields 1b
and coming out of the season when the
season was over before we got into the
draft mode
you would have asked me i would have
said trevor lawrence is 1a
and justin field is 1b and some people
maybe
would have flipped that and then we get
into this these last three or four
months and
of course zach wilson i had him last
year as well he's he's
ultra talented guy and can can create
and and
is not afraid to create which is
important and that's kind of the new
trend
right with these colleagues these
college quarterbacks coming out with
what we're seeing
from patrick mahomes and kyler murray
and baker mayfield it seems like that's
like the the new flavor of the month or
the year for these these nfl teams
but i don't get the criticism of fields
especially he's not accountable or he's
not willing to work hard last one to
show up
first one to leave everything i've ever
been around i've
always walked away with a very favorable
impression of speaking with him
i've never walked away going look good
thing he's physically gifted because
whoa he doesn't have a chance like i
i've never never even occurred to me
i've always thought the opposite always
thought
that he's the alpha in the room like
when he speaks
everybody gets quiet no coaches around
he's the guy
he's the straw that mixes a drink and
hardest worker on the team
and he's a guy that transferred in and
with kind of like russell wilson when he
left nc state
within a month he was voted captain
because he was he had that it factor
that's that's justin fields i mean he
leaves george he's never even been to
ohio
and within a couple months he's the guy
and so
that doesn't just happen at a school
like ohio state
and ryan day you talk to the nfl folks
ryan day is
is respected as a play caller and a guy
that works with quarterback is
anybody that works in the college game
and he would tell you he goes on and on
and on i don't know if you've spoken
with him he goes on and on
bragging about him if you remember when
dwayne haskins came out
he was complimentary but he was kind of
like she'd come back for another year
right he was not going on and on and on
with fields he is and so
i don't i don't get it i don't
understand it um
i i'm still shocked that the jets are
not going to select them i
i still think it's maybe they're just
kind of kidding and
the number two pick will be justin field
i don't know how you pass on him
uh personally with six three 224 pounds
and runs a
a 4-4 not to mention he can make every
throw
uh you know like all these college
quarterbacks it's it's gonna be
it'll take some time as far as him
picking up the
nfl coverage and and doing what he needs
to do
ideally he would go somewhere and you
know kind of have a chance to sit there
and watch and learn from a veteran and
then
kind of like patrick mahomes did year
two take off and go
and become i think an elite player so i
don't know
i'm i'm i'm i'm mystified by the whole
thing
emmy award winner emmy award nominee for
2021
and author kirk herb street here on the
rich eisen show and
you know look this conversation we just
had has taken up a ton of oxygen and
what the niners are gonna do and what
atlanta might do and what the bengals
should do
all of that and we just ignore the fact
that one of the most generationally
talented players at the quarterback
position is going to be first overall
and the guy who's going to draft him is
urban meyer for crying out loud
and the you got two guys and and you
know much was made about
uh trevor lawrence's quotes to sports
illustrated and the things that i made
of it was just
what if justin fields had said it it
would have been just a whole big to do
and the fact that
you know trevor lawrence says that you
know or others say he doesn't really
need football and stuff like that
uh is is unfair uh to him to just to
criticize it
to me it was just i was being critical
of the fact that what if others of josh
rosen had set up for instance a couple
of years ago
but to me my concern is if there is one
at all
is you got quarterback who feels that
way because nobody's ever pointed to the
scoreboard and said you should have a
chip on your shoulder because normally
trevor's winning and urban meyer who
uh i don't know the last time if you if
you'd have to probably go back to
florida to say that he's lost
uh double-digit games just in terms of
uh collectively
how do you think they're gonna take
losing which is going to come
in the nfl how will they handle that of
course collectively
do you think yeah i think i think
keeping an eye on urban
i'm sure every every crew that goes in
on a weekly basis and does a jags game
will have a camera assigned to him
just to watch his some of his reactions
on the sideline
you know because he's he's pretty
animated uh when things are not going
well
i i think urban is when he took the job
and he looked at
you know the the situation in
jacksonville he understood
he's very confident that eventually he's
going to build a winner uh how soon
you know we're all left to guess when
that might be but
i think he understands you know what
he's up against and what he needs to be
able to do
and there's going to be some growing
pains along the way
um i i would say this about trevor
lawrence you know i think the quote
you're referring to
is is basically where he came out and
said you know football
matters to me but it's not it doesn't
define me kind of thing
i i i really feel like keep in mind that
this kid lost
he started since he was a freshman in
high school he lost two games in high
school
he lost two games in college as a
three-year starter
he got to the national championship and
won as a freshman got their second year
lost it to bam and then loses to ohio
state in the semifinal that that doesn't
happen
ever three three years and and that kind
of production had two losses
this kid has a fire inside him that he
doesn't necessarily show
on the exterior he is really
legitimately
walks the walk with his faith and i
think what he
meant by what he was saying was this
the results of this game whether we win
a super bowl or we lose a lot of games
i'm still gonna be who i am i think
that's what he was trying to say i don't
think he was trying to say
i think that's why he came back out on
the on the i think he tweeted out
hey you guys some of you guys are
misunderstanding what i was trying to
say
i think he's got a a burning desire to
win i mean how could you have those
results
four losses in seven seasons of starting
um it's great to not be competitive like
i
i don't know how many kids do you know
that you've ever covered that started
quarterback as a freshman in high school
i'm more impressed that he started
having four sons i'm more impressed that
he started as a freshman in high school
that's a 14 15 year old
playing against 18 year olds it's crazy
kirk hard
thing to do yeah that's to me ridiculous
yeah it is i know i know and we've i
we i i've talked about it with albert
breer and and like the only
person you could kind of compare him to
maybe
being first overall in the draft is
andrew luck and then peyton manning
before in terms of what you're bringing
into it and
again i have no problem with what he had
to say because you know better
than most having covered a lot of these
guys in college and then
four years later these big men on campus
have to figure out what to do next in
their lives and i'm not saying that's
going to happen to trevor just on
average right so i love the fact that
guys come into the draft
saying that there's more to life than
just football i have no problem with
that i'm just wondering
hey he he might he said two losses in
high school
two losses in in college he may have
more than that by
halloween to say the least you know and
and how is he gonna handle like he may
get a chip pretty damn fast
him and urban together you know like
that's my question the one thing i
he used to tell me and i what i really
liked about him because when you look at
him you don't think this he's six six
220 pounds and
you know he's a quarterback but you go
back to the ohio state clemson game not
this year but last year when he got hit
by sean wade on that blitz and right it
looked like he may have broken his
collarbone and was going to be out of
the game and he goes out for a couple
plays comes back in and leads him back
to a victory
and ran the ball that night better than
he threw it i mean he was running
and i said i talked to him about that
with no cameras around i just talked to
him and he said you know i've always
tried to
look at myself and this goes back
probably my high school coach
i want in my mind be the toughest guy on
the field like i i want to be
i don't i don't want to be the
quarterback that can't be touched don't
hit me
you know i've got the red jersey on and
so his mentality
it tells you about a toughness that he
brings to the position because
when i evaluate quarterbacks you know
it's great to look at luck and peyton
and trevor
and their physicality and their size and
their arm strength
but i love the intangibles i think any
great quarterback
who's gonna and you look at the guys
today in the nfl the guys that win and
tom brady
at the top of the list the mental
toughness that they bring
the intangibles that they bring to the
table the way they make the room
feel we're gonna win today i don't care
about the weather
i don't care if we're playing home or
away i don't care what the odds are
we got our guy we're gonna win today
he's gonna bring
that element into that locker room so it
made they're made like peyton
had in in indy there may be some growing
pains
but don't ever underestimate the
intangibles of what he'll bring to the
position i i think that part of it
may be his greatest quality kirk herb
street espn college football analyst and
he'll be part of you you're with reese
right
on abc yeah and mcshane and todd mchale
on abc on thursday and
friday night i you don't need to know
this more than you probably already do
but dez is one of my favorite people on
planet earth
no of course of course he is are you
kidding me just in terms of joy that
he's brought to me and just the person
that he is on top of it
yeah he's awesome did beau ever try to
recruit you did beau ever knock on your
door bo did
both did bo and my dad coached together
and we're good friends and so after my
junior year i went up to ann arbor
and um we were going to go up and on a
fishing trip and
bo asked my dad if we'd stopped by sure
and uh he wanted to talk to us and i did
and he pulled me into my his office by
himself he asked my dad to walk out
and he basically looked at me right in
the eye with his glasses on
and i was a bow fan i was like he was
like
sure i bow down the bow and when you
grow up with my family
and even though he's michigan it's all
good and he's like
can i re accusing can i recruit you are
you going to ohio state is it like is it
done
or can i can i recruit you and i was
like no i'd be an honor for you to
recruit me and of course in the back of
my mind i knew i was going to go to ohio
state i wanted to be recruited
i wanted to be recruited by beau so
there was no way i was going to say
yeah don't worry about it i'm going to
ohio state but no i was all about jerry
hanlon michigan
oh yeah i was yeah well if you're from
if you're from ohio in that era in the
in the mid 80s
you know michigan was all over ohio well
look at some of the greatest players in
the history of michigan football they're
from ohio i mean oh yeah charles
i mean right yeah i mean please i mean
the list goes on and on
yeah when they were rolling they they
had northeastern ohio occasionally
they'd get into southwest ohio but that
northeastern ohio was like a pipeline
you know going for of course with beau
and his ties into ohio but
yeah they're that that's when uh that's
when they were
at a very different level i hope they
get back to that level i i miss that to
be honest
well that sounds like a very passive
aggressive thing to say to me kirk i'm
not gonna lie to you oh no i'm sick
no man i do i'm not your typical no i
know that
i know that i know that i pulled from
michigan every game except
one that's yeah no i get it no i i
totally understand that
you know but it's good for the big ten
right no it's just you're piling it on
now
you're piling it on right now
i'm serious by the way i covered beau in
his last season for the michigan daily
um and i was scared of him there's no
other way to put her i was
so intimidated by him and
um he had a weekly press conference
at a local you know inn and
we would sit in at this big dining room
table and he would sit at the head of it
right
and um and he would hold court and i
barely asked a question because i was so
damn nervous and i got
kirk i got there early one time i got
there early one time and i'm sitting
there and i'm having lunch it's a
hamburger
and who comes walking in but bo and he
sits down at the head of the table
and i don't say a word he doesn't say a
word and then he looks at me and i look
at him
and he goes how is that my doctor won't
let me
let me eat any of those anymore and i'm
like
coach i'm not gonna lie to you it's
pretty damn good and he goes
damn it and other people then walked in
the room so i didn't have to have more
of a conversation with him
but that's basically my interaction with
bo my first ever
and then you know bobby knight had that
same kind of vibe about him
no doubt like bobby i mean it's like
bobby and i used to walk in there
when i was doing local radio in columbus
i used to walk into a pro
post game presser there was no chance i
was gonna ask a question i just wanted
to watch
i just want to watch people ask him
questions and have him look at them like
did you seriously just ask me that
question
he wanted my hamburger so bad it was so
funny because you know he had all those
heart problems his doctor would let him
have it
uh before i let you go let's talk about
your book why'd you
what's what's this about why'd you do it
what do you got for me on that kirk uh
gene wojcikowski who i work with espn
you know phenomenal um
he's a great guy and he's he's brought
it up to me in the past and
when kobe hit last march he he came up
to me or called me in april and asked me
to find the interest i've always kind of
thought i'd do that down the road and
then when when the world went upside
down i thought
this may be a good time to look back and
and think about some of the things i've
been through just just my own personal
journey of
of uh some stuff that i i went through
that maybe can help other kids you know
i was i was painfully shy i'm talking
like would never give up and give a
speech in a class or
um just hard for me to make friends
just a really really quiet introverted
kid
and my parents divorced when i was eight
or nine years old and so between
moving constantly and being you know shy
i just thought when i tell people that
story they're like what are you kidding
me and i
just it just it's an example of how life
changes you know how you change and grow
and so we just talked about
it's a lot of football but there's a lot
of stuff of my on my personal journey of
stuff i've been through
um it's not just exo's and football at
all so i think it's
something that a lot of people can
relate to and it's uh where all books
are sold you with gene wojciechowski
um football fatherhood and college game
day saturdays kirk you and i know a lot
of the same people
uh fowler is one of my favorite on the
planet is uh
his better half jennifer um reese who
you're going to be broadcasting with i
did sports centers with in 1996 oh yeah
so you know you're you're you're a
fortunate man to work with those people
and i love you and fowler
you and fowler are great listen just
terrific thank you big time
yeah i'm lucky to to be with him and um
big fan of yours always have been and
good to see you from time to time and
appreciate you having me on and
congratulations on
on your well-deserved emmy nomination as
well right back at you kirk i'll see you
in ohio
i'll see you okay i might be less
popular than you there but uh i'm going
to use you as a human shield
for just a few minutes if you don't got
it okay you got it take care that's kirk
curb street everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here